hello my name is Dustin Kirkland I'm a
product manager at Google and I'm here
with Weston Hutchins who's also a
product manager working on gke everyone
loves a good origin story Wes you've
been with with gke on-prem since the
beginning what is the origin story of
gke on premise so thanks for having me
here Dustin you know GK and Prem really
started by talking to gke customers so
these were people that had decided they
were using kubernetes and they were
loving the managed experience we give
them in the cloud but they needed a
solution that runs in their own data
center for a variety of reasons mainly
regulatory some some of them had
workloads that they couldn't really
bring up to the cloud quite yet legacy
things and they were looking for a
solution that worked in both places they
had been using primarily do-it-yourself
kubernetes which is pretty easy to get
up and running but the real challenge
comes on the the day to operations so
things like securing your cluster doing
it in high availability mode just being
able to scale up the cluster up and down
these are all things that GK does really
well and we we talked to a lot of them
and we I went and talked to a couple of
devs inside and we said hey is it
possible to take the GK Management stack
all the cluster management that we do
and a lot of the node features wrap that
up into a package and bring it into a
customer's on-prem environment and at
first people were like oh I don't know
but over time you know we started to
pull together prototypes and pieces and
we built a a package that we could give
off to customers that was then connected
back to our sort of hosted control plan
that offers a local kubernetes cluster
running in a datacenter and you know
when we talked a lot about anthos at
next this year kubernetes and GK on-prem
really formed the base of that package
and we then start to layer other types
of services and I will say ease-of-use
features for developers like sto and Kay
native that can run in this portable
environment where you can run it in
other clouds and you can run it in an
on-prem place so that's really how G
come from King and GK on-prem is
ultimately the heart of anthems it is
the kubernetes is sort of the base
underpinning of all of the stuff we
build on it gives us that portable
at environment that infrastructure
abstraction that allows you to run the
same workloads in different places
without having to change anything it all
starts with the G ke on Prem and then
the end those pieces plug in around them
correct yeah the the the base layer is
kubernetes it is the portable
infrastructure abstraction that allows
us to run in and on Prem environment and
in the cloud and then the other ones
built on top and but kubernetes by
itself just isn't enough right so what
are the other key pieces that plug in
that that make it enough
yeah kubernetes is extremely powerful
but for a lot of a lot of customers I
talked to you especially developers they
don't really want all the bells and
whistles and knobs of kubernetes and
this is really where Kay native and
cloud run fit in they say you can take
the normal app development workflow that
you're used to so push to deploy build
in the cloud builds an app have
different versions scale those out and
under the covers that will actually go
and configure traffic splitting services
and kubernetes add load balancers scale
up app scaled down apps that's really
you know what kubernetes is supposed to
be it's the base layer that gets it done
but we want to make things easier for
developers and operators and is this
meeting those those same customers that
you talked to at the beginning that
didn't want those day-to-day 92
operations I don't want to worry about
those operations and that management are
we hitting the mark here yeah you know
for the most part most customers don't
really want to be in the business of
operating managing their own cluster
they would rather let someone that knows
how to do this at scale with many many
customers take that over for them so
they can just focus on writing apps
right and what what are you hearing in
terms of hybrid workloads and the
challenges and solutions to hybrid
computing yeah so the biggest challenge
that we ran into is just you know a lot
of these customers either have data that
could not leave the data center for
regulatory reasons or maybe they need to
run workloads at the edge so superfast
low latency processing they have
standardized on kubernetes they said
that is the the app platform that we
want to use in the cloud and in these
environments but we really need a full
manage stack running in these places and
so G Khan Prem does give them that
ability to keep data local to to work
within their existing regulatory
environments but also offers them a path
forward to cloud like this is the real
big key benefit of anthos is that you
can start to use cloud workflows right
you can start to think about writing
apps that are resilient to clusters that
nodes that can go down you can start
thinking about global apps and how to do
traffic splitting across them but you
can use that in your own environment
when you're ready you can move up to the
cloud at your own pace it's a real
hybrid world yeah for a lot of customers
it really is about training and the the
people that you hire training them on
the right tools so they don't have to
learn different types of tooling for
these different environments that's a
lot of the magic of what anthos brings
Wes thank you very much absolutely thank
you
[Music]
you